[Música]
hace un año nos trajimos a casa un
trípode y una cámara y ese mismo tiempo
un año es lo que llevan parados miles de
profesionales de la cultura siendo los
del espectáculo en los más perjudicados
por eso en francia han dicho hasta aquí
y lo que inició el 4 de marzo como una
apropiación del teatro parisino odeón se
ha convertido en un movimiento de
ocupación de más de 30 espacios
incluyendo ultramar
en mayo del 68 odeón fue uno de los
centros de la revolución y hoy tiene
simbolismo que haya animado a todo tipo
de salas a organizarse contra un cierre
que nos lastra desde octubre si bien una
reapertura es solo el punto de
convergencia de una lucha social mayor
para que el gobierno dé mejores ayudas y
no endurezca como prevé las condiciones
de desempleo de ahí que la protesta
reúna a artistas estudiantes
intermitentes hasta el turismo y cines
con sesiones clandestinas
el elíseo repartirá 50 millones de euros
a teatros grupos de danza y música
apoyar a los recién diplomados y a
quienes no adoptaron el dispositivo año
blanco pero para muchos no basta porque
no llega a la mayoría
[Música]
los textos franceses que alzaron a
scioli con como mejor cinta fue un
altavoz de esa rabia porque los cines a
diferencia de tiendas o iglesias han
estado clausurados 8 de 12 meses
impidiendo ver joyas como la ganadora a
mejor animación josep hoy ya está en
amazon pero su historia pasa inadvertida
como la desmemoria que tiene españa por
ella y es que en 1939 con la guerra
civil de cantada hasta 500.000 españoles
huyeron del fascismo hasta francia sólo
que en vez de ser acogidos los
encerraron en campos de concentración y
los trataron como animales con
beneplácito franquista entre ellos
estaba el dibujante catalán josep
bartolí cuyo retrato por siete campos y
su salvación en mexico horrorizó y
sedujo al ilustrador francés o girl o
gel se topó con el libro de marcel y de
casualidad pero además de rescatar este
exilio con él con los refugiados de hoy
quiso plasmar que el acto de dibujar
también es esperanza y en el caso de
bártoli resistencia denuncia y cómic
futurista de 1943 que españa no editó
hasta 2007
joaquín ariza perfil del fondo muere de
ese folk y si el 22 fue mal allí papel
envié
[Música]
si conocen a esta mujer su novio no
tiene noticias diciendo
[Música]
me lo franco española lo franco latino
la dirección de patrimonio dedicó su más
reciente libro a oscar niemeyer y no
pudimos no hacer escala en la genialidad
del padre de brasilia que con hormigón
alzó a latinoamérica actual
arquitectónico este material suena frío
salvo que niemeyer lo moldeó con las
curvas de su brasil y lo impregnó de un
espíritu optimista no visto en los
espacios no se agrandaba lo socializaba
debido también a su convicción de
izquierdas premio pritzker los oscar de
la arquitectura le encantaba la vida y
la estiró hasta los 104 años dejando 600
negados como la sede de la onu en nueva
york el sambódromo o estos que revela a
erika olavarría en francia donde firmó
seis edificios
un ovni el vientre de una mujer
embarazada las ideas de los comunistas
eran prolífica según el arquitecto
brasileño oscar niemeyer y es lo que
quiso reflejar al diseñar la sede del
partido comunista francés en los 70 en
meissen se tache texto y uso de esta
arquitectura en escena con un edificio
de oficinas con muro de vidrio espacio
para colgar publicidad política y
delante un domo que acoge la sala del
comité central del partido comunista
menú apagó y vanesa grossman recuerdan
en un libro la variada huella que el
padre de brasilia dejó en francia donde
se exilió en 1966 dos años después del
inicio de la dictadura en brasil la sede
del partido su obra más conocida pero no
fue el único pedido que el arquitecto
comunista recibió esta casa política
también lo fue este edificio que alberga
los sindicatos en una comuna obrera de
la periferia de parís
allí repitió el conjunto de un edificio
de vidrio y un volumen curvilíneo al
interior el auditorio fue pintado de los
colores de brasil
en los 80 niemeyer regreso a brasil pero
volvió a parís a levantar la sede del
periódico comunista alimente los
críticos de la arquitectura moderna lo
atacaron a él también con las opas tico
minis al final se le asocia al partido
comunista lo que no es percibido como
positivo y en los 2000 casi a sus 100
años vemos que aquello sentido como
repetido es apreciado en su justo valor
y lumen y te están también las curvas y
los muros de vidrios reflectantes
necesarios para darle visibilidad a su
célebre vecina la catedral de son denis
el primer edificio gótico del mundo
y la música es nuestra guinda repasando
primero los hitos de unos grammy
pandémicos sí pero con gran voluntad de
normalidad
beyonce se erigió artista femenina con
más gramófonos mientras que taylor swift
logró ser la primera mujer en ganar tres
veces el álbum del año empatando con
frank sinatra stevie wonder y paul simon
por su parte en bilis va viéndose camino
entre grabaciones y consiguiendo algo
tan raro como que un tema para cine el
de james bond haya triunfado sin haberse
estrenado ojo no veamos el triunfo de
mat bonnie y natalia lafourcade grupo
niche y fito páez pero de esas buenas
vibras queremos más y la ítalo brasileña
daiane las mezcla aquí con su dedicación
por la música aunque cueste llegar a las
metas
y sostiene raros al entorno lanzando
vuestro corazón
para cuando quiero
si bien imposible no despedirse con él y
su boda por la fugacidad de los momentos
y las relaciones que esperamos no
terminan con frases o gestos sin decir o
hacer muchísimas gracias y cuídense
[Música]
digo yo